from watching Josh Allen before you on
this team did you think he was as good
as he is right now I knew he was good
um
we played we play uh the bills in 2019 I
think we played the bills in 2019. he
was on his he was yeah yeah we played
the bills in 2019 I think so yeah yeah
sometimes
we played the visit 2019 and I I just
remember like going against Josh and him
he was running around usually that
quarterback and running around and step
out of Bounce and just like ran around
and took it was like 60 yards I'm like
bro like who does that bro what are you
doing like he went crazy that game so I
knew it and then like over time just me
being a fan of the league and like
eventually I want to be like a GM so you
got to pay attention to college and like
other players around the league so I
seen Josh's uh Evolution throughout all
his time and I saw like in particular
like last season like he just continued
to take these steps so I knew like Josh
was Josh Allen but seeing it up close
and personal like hearing practice like
being around them in the locker room
like [ __ ] uh seeing them like kicking
at his house playing Blu-ray and like
being around like just being around him
in general it made me it made me really
realize like hey this guy is like
special it's not just like one of those
it's like one of those flute gears what
do you how you feel about Josh of course
of course we got you know we got this
coming up in a segment can't stand him
okay uh uh Josh got one of those like
fairy tale ass stories you know like
it's kind of weird but you know a kid
out of Wyoming Big Arm you know saying
going in the draft and then his first
couple years he had some success and
then like I kind of knew about Josh
already because they came and kicked our
ass in Minnesota one year like you know
we had we were 17 point favorites going
into the game and we got the Bobby right
after so we got our mindset on [ __ ] like
Buffalo coming we going all right we're
gonna walk them and we go to the bar so
they came in they came up with the right
monster I think they went up two scores
like in the first or second quarter like
this oh hold the [ __ ] up hold up what's
going on and then I was like this [ __ ]
like y'all better get y'all [ __ ]
together they about to beat the [ __ ] out
of us and then next thing you know like
we're down like 20 points or something
crazy and I'm like this damn we about to
really bought it really lose to the
bills I'm like [ __ ] well game's over now
bye week here I come and then that was
my only thing I had registered in my
brain as I was about to get traded so as
I'm about to get traded and I had the
team to choose from
I was just I had a I had a clear image
of Josh Allen in my brain and then like
they had went to the playoffs against
Houston the year before and like he had
a half of a game he like caught a
touchdown like a pastor he threw him a
touchdown he had threw some [ __ ] he had
ran and I was like I don't know what
y'all talking about but he a winner like
he a dog yes he is so I uh when I got
traded or whatever I had met him in the
offices I'm like damn he kind of you
know how you meet somebody and it's like
you might not like immediately like
click but it's like this damn like he
cool as [ __ ] like I could you know what
I'm saying like that [ __ ] all right so I
kind of went in with that mindset and
then moving forward as a season start
progression I was like this [ __ ] like
Josh Josh cool as [ __ ] like we would
play the game together like little kid
[ __ ] that adults usually don't typically
do and I was like damn like I [ __ ] with
Josh and then like as the season went on
we had a lot of success together and him
throwing me the ball and [ __ ] like that
like I owe him a lot of credit to my
success uh especially going into a new
new team where you know I'm saying a lot
sometimes [ __ ] don't go right yeah I'm
saying and this is one of those stories
that well it did yeah when I first and
foremost I always thank God but then I
always give a lot of credit to jobs like
even that first year he won't tell you
this but that first year I felt like uh
I felt like he
he kind of like changed my career to the
point where I wanted to be I wanted to
Blossom and I wanted to turn into one of
the top receivers in the league and he
helped with that so for Christmas I had
got him a little uh I had bought him
like a watch like a nice little nice
little watch a little uh what was it it
was something it was something small I
asked him about it I bought him a little
watch for Christmas he was happy about
it but it was just something that I was
like [ __ ] bro you you were part of My
Success so I wanted to show my gratitude
to him and you know about not only that
just getting open to catching the ball
for him because my job is to keep him
looking good too